sous ces quelques centimètres de neige
siatoysk et meurtri libéré en septembre
cette ville du nord de Donetsk garde les
stigmates de ses combats les rares
habitants qui sont restés se rappellent
de leur vie d'avant
on avait une si belle mairie ils ont
tout détruit
ici les habitants n'ont plus rien seul
l'ONG World centrale kitchen et ses
bénévoles se relaient pour aider les
gens présents sur place mais c'était
bien venu peut paraître bien maigre face
à la détresse des habitants
donc c'était terrifiant vous savez
terrifiant je ne sais pas quoi faire
j'aimerais tellement retrouver la paix
je suis né pendant la Seconde Guerre
mondiale
et je mourrais pendant cette guerre
pourquoi
dans la région de données les habitants
ressentent de plus en plus les coupures
d'électricité et les pénurie alors même
que la Russie continue d'intensifier ses
attaques dans la région